[Musique]
ce qu'on remarque aussi pendant cette
pandémie c'est l'impact sur les surdoses
elles sont en hausse
il ya même on le voit ça d'un bout à
l'autre du pays le nombre de morts
augmente et à montréal sa double et 23
personnes sont décédées de surdoses
plusieurs se demandent s'ils devraient
pas aborder le problème de dépendance
autrement j'en ai discuté avec docteur
marième aurait elle est médecin de
famille elle travaille en dépendance et
en santé mentale l'on sert de terreau
murray bonjour madame drôle et vous
l'avez noté aussi dans votre clinique
avec votre expertise qui avait une
augmentation de surdoses cet été est
fait il ya une augmentation de la
consommation
il ya des gens qui ne consommaient pas
avant qu'ils se sont mis à consommer y
en a qui consomme elle déjà qui ont
consommé plus est malheureusement oui
pour plusieurs raisons qu'on va
expliquer il ya eu une augmentation des
surdoses pas juste dans l'ouest canadien
mais au québec aussi
est ce que vous faites le lien avec la
pandémie a fait tout à fait 12 heures
prenons un des premiers facteurs le
confinement
1 le confinement votre complètement à
l'encontre de toutes les recommandations
médicales
on peut faire à quelqu'un qui voit pas
bien qui sont non pharmacologiques s'est
perdu et si vous faites une dépression -
tant que médecin je vais vous dire aller
au gym
ne vous isolez pas appeler des amis vous
compenser ça qu'on fait comme
recommandation gens alors que le balcon
finances était tout à fait inverse et l
isolement ne pas voir les associations
sociales et tout se crée chez beaucoup
de gens pour ne pas dire tout le monde
de l'anxiété ou la dépression c'est pas
tout le monde qui gère l'anxiété de la
même façon et on sait aussi qu'un autre
facteur à considérer c'est la façon dont
on a géré système de santé au début de
la pandémie je veux dire on a
complètement mobilisé le système de
santé au complet ou presque pour le coc
vide de choc qui a des gens qui auraient
peut-être dû consulter un médecin
pendant la pandémie qui ne l'ont pas
fait parce qu'avais par-delà l'hôpital
parce qu'elle avait peur d'être infectés
alors il ya beaucoup de jeunes se sont
mis à s'automédicamenter prenons
l'alcool par exemple donc l'alcool ça
calme ça fait du bien sur le coup ça
l'aide à dormir et on sait que les
ventes de la saq ont exclu
dès le début de la pandémie c'est un
exemple et et c'était un peu la même
chose du côté des drogues mais est-ce
que des drogues en particulier que vous
notez qu'ils qui sont beaucoup plus
utilisés qu'avant plus utilisé je ne
pourrais vous dire mais de beaucoup plus
piètre qualité
oui entre autres la cocaïne en ce moment
la cocaïne l'héroïne même la kétamine
il ya certaines drogues en toi qui sont
importés habituellement donc on sait que
les frontières ont été fermées
on sait que importer un kilo de cocaïne
en ce moment c'est pas aussi évident
peut-être qu'il ya un an et les prix de
ces drogues là ont bondi en flèche
donc en tant que trafiquants ou vendeurs
de drogue
si on veut continuer à vendre marché et
vendre le même prix qu'à l'habitude une
des seule option c'est de couper la
drogue avec une autre substance qui
coûtent moins chers ou qu'ils aient de
moins bonne qualité
et tout ça bien sûr a eu un impact sur
la santé des utilisateurs c'est ce que
vous avez noté cet été on a vu qu'on
voit beaucoup de caen je voudrais des
réactions on voit beaucoup de réactions
psychiatre et caen donc des pressions
l'accepter des nouvelles dépendances
on a vu des gens qui se sont retrouvés à
la rue il ya un autre selon l'impression
qu'ils en ont de plus en plus aussi donc
penser penser seulement ou carrément le
sur notre dame le quai des gens qui
donnent dans des tentes
qu'est ce que ces gens là vont faire au
mois de novembre au mois de décembre on
ne sait pas bien aux facteurs je pense
est important de mentionner la fameuse
pcu l'apc où c'était une mesure
d'urgence extrêmement important qui est
évitable dans beaucoup de cas mais soyez
assuré aussi que beaucoup de gens qui
ont eu la pcu qu'il n'y avait pas
nécessairement droit et qui ont consommé
avec cet argent loi y en eu amplement de
sûr malheureusement alors vous faites le
lien ce moment là de l'argent disponible
donc à ce moment le plus plus de
dépendance ou plus de consommation de
drogue
ben il ya eu qu'une beaucoup de
consommation il y en a encore beaucoup
je voudrais si la droite ne faisait pas
de bien ou de neu neu neu sous les jets
pas les malades il ya un beau tandja qui
en consommeraient et lorsque je pense
que c'est important de mentionner
la dépendance n'est pas une mauvaise
habitude c'est une maladie et si ce
n'était pas une maladie tout le monde
serait alcoolique
parce que tout le monde me surprend pas
un petit verre de vin alors que c'est en
15 à 20% de la population qui ont des
problèmes avec l'alcool mais on veut des
changements on voit il ya des
changements d'attitude ou de
compréhension jeu souvent ces dossiers
là vous c'est votre domaine vous êtes
vraiment experte là dedans vous avez
développé une sensibilité et un regard
là-dessus mais cet été on entend du
docteur des réseaux tam qui est
l'administratrice en chef de santé
canada elle a laissé entendre que ce
serait le temps pour le gouvernement de
seulement de commencer à songer à
décriminaliser les drogues dures
écoutez même l'association canadienne
des chefs de police il faudrait
peut-être décriminaliser à tout le moins
la possession simple de drogues
illégales on n'est plus dans le cannabis
là on est dans les autres types de
drogues à vue ou la baisse on s'achemine
cette idée là on a des cas aussi dans le
premier ministre en colombie-britannique
qui semble assez ouvert et assez pro
actif avec ses idées ben non seulement
j'ose espérer que ça chemine mais c'est
un incontournable
on est vraiment rendu le avec la crise
des opioïdes qu'on a connu avec la
pandémie qu'ovide qu'on vit en ce moment
et avec le fait que consommer de la
drogue ce n'est pas un crime c'est une
maladie et je ne comprends pas pourquoi
on criminalise un héroïnomane par
exemple qu'il avait acheté une dose
d'héroïne alors qu'il n'a pas commis de
crime puis écouter un dossier criminel
ans a des impacts pour le reste de nos
vies
ce n'est pas banal et si on pouvait à
aider ces gens là au lieu les
criminaliser on réduira les coûts
sociaux au niveau des prisons au lieu
des plus de gens qui se rétablirait et
on pourrait enfin peut-être mieux
adresser des problèmes de santé mentale
qu'on voit chez des personnes
dépendantes
oui vous par les y est monterrey
j'aurais voulu amener sur le dossier de
la santé mentale vous faites partie de
ceux qui lisse en boule et de le faire
d'ailleurs pendant notre entrevue
vouliez justement la détresse sa santé
mentale et la consommation de toute
sorte de drogue qu'ils peuvent devient
très très dangereuse
on entend encore parler de psychiatres
qui disent moi je prendrais pas ce
patient là et je demande aux pacers
allait régler votre problème de
dépendance
vient ensuite on parle de votre santé
mentale mais vous l'impression qu'il ya
encore beaucoup de travail à faire de ce
côté là énormément de travail à faire au
niveau
la comorbidité c'est à dire la présence
d'une maladie mentale sur laquelle s'est
greffée une dépendance quelle qu'elle
soit et on sait que ça ça touche 50 à
70% des personnes dépendantes
donc on ne peut pas exclure on ne peut
pas dissocier la santé mentale de
l'indépendance et je rajouterais même à
ce que la toxicomanie la dépendance
c'est un chapitre dans le dsm le livre
de la psychiatrie qu'on utilise dans le
monde entier donc commencions car
aujourd'hui on envoie les gens
psychiatrique un toxico parce qu'ils
consomment et on envoie les gens
suicidaire en psychiatrie parce qu'ils
sont suisses dans les consoles
bref souvent les gens tombent encore
malheureusement en deux files et c'est
pas pour rien quand il ya autant de
suicides chez les toxicomanes
c'est une approche que vous vous avez
privilégié dans votre pratique avec
votre clinique qui s'appelle caméléon
c'est votre dernière journée aujourd'hui
à votre chronique vous vous mettez la
clé sous la porte c'est le cas de le
dire vous avez pas eu financement dont
vous aviez besoin vous aller travailler
ailleurs
vos passions pour vous suivre ou est-ce
que vous allez travailler le dr morin
oui je m'en vais à la clinique du mont
carmel que tu ne finis qui est ingénieur
qui est situé juste en face de radio
canada ou ailleurs et c'est une clinique
qui existe depuis plus de vingt ou
trente ans roger auque on craint que sa
ferme dans le matin je vais me joindre à
des collègues et je les remercie déjà à
la vente de m'accepter avec un clientèle
coloris ce sont des cas millions dont
qu'il saddam mais c'est parfois déjà
coloré et à la clinique du mont carmel
on m'a accueilli à bras ouverts j'ai
très hâte de les rejoindre je vais
commencer le mois d'octobre et étant
donné que je ferais plus autant de
gestion je vais avoir peut-être plus de
temps pour recommencer à prendre des
nouveaux patients doivent écouter on
vous souhaite une belle suite des choses
il a continué de faire oeuvre utile
merci beaucoup pour cette entrevue merci
pour votre regard merci madame drolet au
revoir